hey everybody it's Jesse and I've been
gone for a while been on vacation so I
hope everyone had a great week last week
I thought about streaming while I was on
vacation but there's no way Wi-Fi would
have made it work would have been able
to handle it
it could barely handle like streaming
Netflix at times so I did release one
video on my own channel so if you
haven't seen that yet you can check that
out there's a link to my channel in the
description for this video just really
short kind of explaining how I got to be
a front-end developer today I want to
set up some click tracking so I was
asked to track the clicks for every link
that goes back to our main website from
this website so it shouldn't be too
difficult so we're already using we're
already using a let me just let me show
you what it is it's you know like an NPM
module that we've imported and it's
called react ga
so here's reusing and we did do I did do
a stream where we initially set this up
or at least I remember doing a stream
where I was trying to get this to work
and I couldn't get it I don't think I
get it to work out the way I wanted it
to work but at some point I got this
trying to get up to the top here so this
is what we're going to be working with
today and I included a link to this in
the description as well so you can check
it out if you want there's really only
one part of you know it's pretty
well-documented there's only one part of
the
that we're going to look at today that
we're even going to need and it's the
click tracking part let's see there we
go this part I think we're going to try
to use the component version of the
click tracking there shouldn't be too
many links that we have to edit so this
should work
hey everybody ok I see in the live chat
everybody saying hi oh is hello from
Brazil awesome
welcome Oh Sean says back after so long
and I'm left far behind what haven't
done anything for a week so not quite as
behind as as it could have been alright
alright so we got our viewer count is is
up to decent number here so I think
we're going to get started first thing I
do want to show you all is a course a
course that I'm going to be taking and
it looks it looked good and it's
definitely definitely what I'm working
on now so I'm just go throw this in here
I don't know if you saw this I think I
saw it on Twitter first and then
actually then I noticed the email I got
from Udacity after that but I noticed I
saw on Twitter of quite a few retweets
of this course on Udacity so if you've
never done anything with Udacity before
it has a lot of free online courses in a
lot of different areas not just web
development but this will be the first
time I'm actually going to pay for the
nanodegree
so I've already already made my payment
the course is $500
and I'm not like officially recommending
this or anything I haven't even taken it
yet so I'm not sure if it's good but
since I'm building in react and I know
there's going to be a lot of sites that
I will be doing in the future with react
I thought it would be cool to take this
so just wanted to share that it hasn't
even started yet as you can see there's
a countdown timer here so I will let you
all know how the course is this one is
unique a lot of the courses in Udacity
are like totally self-paced this one is
actually it has a definite start and end
time and you have to get everything done
within that amount of time so hopefully
I can do that my schedule is like pretty
busy but I'm hoping to be able to to
stick to this you know this schedule
this for months scheduled for this
course and yeah don't let you know how
it goes and if anybody else has signed
up for this let me know or if you end up
signing up later on let me know whoops
there we go
all right
okay so I do have one question and the
live chat about the analytics that thing
that we're using the react GA the
question from Philip is what are the
advantage of you of coding with this
overusing tag manager well in my case
we're not set up with tag manager right
now so all of our sites
none of our sites are using tag manager
that might change in the future but at
least the easy answer is I might I'm
it's just not set up like that I'm not
the one that actually sets up a lot of
these I set up some of these Google
Analytics properties but not all of them
so I didn't set up a lot of the sites
when I started working here it was
already set up so anyway we might move
to tag manager in the future but for now
we're going to use this I have from what
I have read about tag manager it does
seem like everything is easier with tag
manager especially if you have a lot to
manage and it would just be insane to do
all this manually so I know that's not
really a great answer sorry it's not a
great answer but I don't really want to
try to you know say any more about it
when I'm not knowledgeable enough to
give you a good answer
looking for there we go footer I know we
have some outbound links in the footer
that we're going to be using so we'll
just start there
I'm trying anywhere else we have one in
that in the header as well that maybe
all the places that we need to to do
this for so this is actually going to be
a shorter video than normal I have a
meeting at 3:00 so that there might be
so some changes coming to this site that
we've been working on for the last few
week and all the meeting today and
another meeting Thursday afternoon which
I probably won't be able to stream
Thursday afternoon because of it but
based on what happens in the
to meetings it's possible there could be
significant changes coming to the site
which I don't know to tell you the truth
it doesn't excite me too much
I mean this sites not perfect but I kind
of like where we have it the direction
we're going with it and I don't want to
have to redo things that we've already
done I wouldn't mind adding new features
that'd be nice but I'd hate to you know
go back over things since we put so much
time into it so many long hours it would
it would be a little bit terrible to
have to go back in and I either
completely take out or redo things that
we spent so much time on so I'll let you
know how that goes all right so I'm
gonna move this these instructions over
to my other screen so that I can look at
these while we're while I'm coding so
like I said before the link to the
instructions remember following is in
the show description so it looks like
and we're going to test this and I
picked this on purpose because I think
this is going to be simple I think it's
gonna be pretty easy and I don't have a
lot of time to stream today so it looks
like all we're gonna have to do is make
sure that we include react GA here and
then we're going to use the react GA dot
outbound link component and all we have
to do we bring it in for a second since
I'm talking about it all we have to do
then is then add an event label and a
two
so basically so instead of like an a tag
we'll replace it with this tag and then
we put in the link text as normal so
hopefully that works and we'll test it
out I have my Google Analytics open
already on my other window I'll bring
that in when it's time to test it but
that's the plan so I'm just going to
grab I want to check out in our
analytics J's file import all right Y
type it when I can just copy and paste
so I'm going to take that and then I'm
going to go back up here to footer and
[Music]
I'm going to report that as well and now
let's find over yet
here we go so this is what we want - any
links to the main website or what we
want to actually let me let me check one
of my Trello board this is where we have
everything that needs to be done and has
already been done all the tasks for the
site yep it is just Franciscan dot edu
okay I just wanted to double-check
before we started doing this that I had
the right length so let's change this to
react ta dot outbound
and same thing here okay now we need I'm
going to copy some of this here
I guess we just need to label alright so
I'm assuming it doesn't show this in the
instructions but I'm assuming we can
still have a title tag and it would just
go right here so I'm going to leave the
title tag in there that's pretty
standard on a link tag so hopefully that
still works so I guess for the label
we'll just say to francisc and I wonder
if I can and you know about this to main
site all right that's basically what we
call it around here Franciscan dot e to
use is always either called the dot edu
or the main site so that'll work for us
and you can change this href to a two
all right
like I said I said I don't know if this
title having a title here or mess it up
it doesn't say anything about it and
documentation so I'm going to leave it
in there for now see if it works so
everything else should work I'm going to
say this I do want to check out to make
sure that it doesn't mess with the
display
all right so it looks like I'm gonna
bring this over so y'all can see it so
this is the link that I changed down
here and it looks like the title is
still working awesome I'm going to click
it what pop uh plugs yes I always allow
pop-ups from low blows all right so it
looks like it's trying to go there so
the main site just happens to be really
slow great so that went to the right
place now let's bring over our analytics
our analytics dashboard here so if you
haven't seen the new Google Analytics
dashboard this is it so this is actually
the first time I saw it I haven't
checked analytics since this happened
this is pretty recent within the last I
don't know a week or so right so we
should be able to go it looks like all
this stuff over here is still the same
so hopefully it is let's see events
let's see if we had an event happen
hmm sick we didn't have anything happen
it's it's possible that I'm not going to
see it until I make this live
so let's so actually working on some
stuff earlier that I forgot to commit so
let me bring this over I'm just going to
do a
I'm going to commit this I'm going to
push it to github and we're actually
we're going to pull this live the stuff
I was working on some stuff earlier but
I've tested it out I think everything's
working well most of it was just really
minor things so let's do
all right so I was working on the events
page and I'm not going to say anything
about the link tracking yet I'm not sure
if it even works
but it's a good sign that we didn't get
an error message at least okay now
here's our servers alright let's see if
you get the IP here we go
I turned my computer off and turn it
back on and for some reason my normally
I have a history of all the commands and
it's separated per tab but it's not it's
not working out like it normally does
all right so let's update so if you
remember from previous episodes we have
load balancing happening so just to
explain in case anyone missed it all
we're doing right now with this long
string of commands which I just copy and
paste it in we're stopping nginx we're
stopping the react app we're going into
the directory where our project lives
and we're pulling in the changes from
github we're installing anything that
there's new any new packages that need
to be installed we're building it and
then starting it again
and then starting engine X that ensures
that our load balancer routes everything
to the other server while this is down
and then when this is back up then we
can go to the other server and do the
same thing
and while this is how whoops while this
is happening I can catch up on the live
chat since I've been ignoring you all so
far sorry I just feel the pressure today
to be done since I have that meeting so
let's uh let me go back okay there's not
a lot I thought I missed it a lot in the
live chat but it looks like there's not
a whole lot that I missed so I'm going
to go through really quick a with
someone from Dominican Republic awesome
hello from India Andrew asks why
master's degrees are so expensive online
I mean that I think they're expensive
everywhere online or on ground it's
degrees or dis for me being expensive
nowadays yeah I mean I was unless you
really need a master's degree for a job
that you want then I wouldn't do it I
know people to just get done with their
undergraduate degree and they aren't
sure what to do so they just decide to
stay and get their master's degree I
mean if if your family's rich maybe
that's okay but but for me that's that's
not what I did
this too much I mean few scholarships
maybe that would work out but it's just
too expensive especially if you're not
if you don't have you know a pretty good
chance of getting a good-paying job from
it alright if someone says hello from
Iran hello awesome
alright Philip earlier Philip that asks
a question about google tag manager and
he did mention he said it is much easier
so something I yeah I know I didn't
fully answer that question but
definitely if you are setting up a site
in a Google Analytics property for the
first time and you could do it however
you want I recommend checking out tag
manager everything I've seen about it
looks great and
I at some point I would it would be nice
to switch everything that we're doing
here over to tag manager oh no I just
checked out I'm sure you all saw this
but I just checked out the the output
here in the terminal and it looks like
local changes would be overwritten by
the marriage please commit your changes
which stash them before you can merge oh
goodness
okay
all right this is I know what happened
okay so someone else that works with me
here when I was on vacation tried to
make changes directly to the server so
these are those changes I've forgotten
about that so I actually don't I don't
want to keep these changes
- let me actually I wish I don't think
he changed anything that I need to keep
I think I'm good and I can just get rid
of these changes so let's see I wonder
how he did it he must have just used
like Nano or something to edit these
uh-huh okay yeah I I was just thinking
that Patrick Patrick just put in the lab
chat get diff that's yeah I was I was
thinking the only thing that I probably
I do want to keep is this image all
right
let's uh
actually let me check let me check
quickly on I want to see what the
difference is went between this image so
I just want to know what changed with it
all right so here's the one page this is
the live page and here's the image I
think this is the image that we're
talking about here and then this is the
one
they these look nearly identical right
what is the difference here
okay there's one difference in the names
so we definitely do want to keep this
alright so actually we do need to keep
these changes and all right so all right
well this makes things slightly more
difficult and I wonder if the other
server is the same
all right so it's actually not really
that bad that this happened because as I
always say when I make mistakes then you
don't have to make them you can just see
what I did and how I messed it up and
can avoid it hopefully so I yeah so
don't edit files on the server directly
that's a moral of the story and if it
does happen don't forget about it so
let's just yep it's on here too
okay all right so here's what I'm
thinking
here's what I'm going to try to do I'm
going to commit these changes
on one of the servers on just one of the
servers and I'm going to push them shoot
it's like pushing I guess I'll just I'll
commit it I'll merge everything and then
I'll push it back up to the main git
repo and then I'll pull it down to the
other server and then I'll have to pull
everything back down locally does that
make sense I think that yeah that'll I
think that'll work
okay so actually
okay it looks like the changes are just
really really minor all right
[Music]
tell me who you are what
I have to say Who I am alright then
let's say UI
I can't believe a change so simple ended
up not being simple I finally thought I
was going to have an easy one but okay
so at least I can go back to the live
chat while this is working alright great
so I'm going to do get pull and I'll
remember that one okay now unfortunately
I won't really be able to see it on
okay I guess if I want to try to test I
was just thinking about testing these
out I can just pull this down and then
we can make sure that it's working so
I'm gonna bring this over this is our
local version just my server not working
let's see
okay
this is our new one no it's not right
this is still yeah it's yeah it's only
one so okay so that's our new one
so did fully changes down what's the
other thing we have one of the lines up
here I'm not going to try to find a line
but
all right so it looks like that's cool
that works now we can go ahead with
starting to get pull and I need to we
got stopped right in the middle of that
long line of command so we got stopped
right at the get pull part so I'm just
going to copy the rest of the command
and paste it in there so we're going to
do the art NPM install we're going to
run a build process and then we're going
to start ok so a little little
inconvenience there but pretty much
passed it all right
so Sebastian says five hundred yeah
maybe I'll stick to youtube tutorials
he's refering to the Udacity course yeah
I had the I signed up for it last week
when I was on vacation and I actually
had the page open to sign up for the
course on my laptop for like two days
before I made the decision finally to do
it but I thought I don't know I thought
it would motivate me since lately I've
been really slacking on doing tutorials
on my own I thought it would motivate me
if I actually spent the money to do the
course so the plan my plan is to wake up
early before my kids wake up which can
be challenging but to wake up early and
do oh man more more problems so my plan
is to wake up early and maybe like do a
workout I have like a exercise bike in
my basement so maybe I can do my work
for this course while I'm doing you know
a little workout in the morning and then
maybe again like on my lunch break
I'll do the course so I could probably
get in like around 2 hours everyday if
we
with a course and then a little bit on
Saturday I think it said like estimate
is made 12 hours a week so if I do that
then it should be good Monday or Monday
through Saturday I put in 2 hours a day
and it should be my twelve hours and it
should work so hopefully it works out
like that all right let's check out
what's happening here
who
well this is not not good here
so our build is not working
all right Patrick says another reason
not to make changes directly in
production this is justification for a
load balancer stuff you went through I
was just thinking the same thing Patrick
so yes if you I think I mentioned
earlier but this site is using a load
balancer so if one servers down
everything gets directed to another
server so right now the site I'm
assuming is still up because the other
server is fine so since we just since I
don't know what just happened with this
server then at least the site still up
and somebody else asked something like
like with what are you doing and I
edited that but basically what we were
trying to do is something really simple
and it should have worked
but basically some changes were made on
directly on the server that it seems
have messed some things up so we're
trying to sort that out
so let me
this is just really weird
um she
this Patek is Jason
yeah it's not like nothing's changed in
my package.json I haven't really added I
was trying to think if I added any
packages since the last time I pushed
anything to the server and I think no I
really I don't think I've added anything
on the master branch all the stuff that
we've been doing has been on separate
branches and it's not actually even been
merged in one master so yeah so this
should be let's see
I realize we'll probably get the exact
same issue but it's worth the try
occasionally run something a second time
and for some reason it works I also want
to run this locally just to see if
something's I do have you aren't
installed locally so but I want to try
to do it this in the same way way did it
work that time you gotta be kidding me
there's no way all right let's all right
so the next command would be
it works alright alright this is if
anybody knows what just happened here
fill me in but it's obviously the first
time this was run we got all these
errors the second time I got nothing oh
well so I'm going to continue with the
rest of the commands to restart this
server
and then we'll check it out so at this
point we should just restart we're using
PM 2 to start things up ok and what I
want to do is I want to try to go
directly to this IP I think if I go
directly to that IP address I can get
right to that server and won't get
switched over to the other server so we
want it to look like so basically we'll
be able to tell if we've gone right to
that server if it's worked if we if this
area has changed significantly
and say yep there we go okay so
everything has changed correctly I'm
just going to inspect really quick to
see if we're getting any weird errors
okay so we're getting this weird error a
page does not exist speaking the truth
and love conference so I'm trying to
prefetch this page and maybe prefetching
doesn't work with the dynamically yet so
let me I do want to test this link hmm
all right so that link doesn't work it's
this actually did work locally so I did
test it earlier this is from something I
tried to do earlier today all right so
aside from that which can be changed
really quickly aside from that this is
pretty much working so it's working
enough that we can at least try to to
test what we were going to we were
initially trying to test so let me find
my analytics and let's see actually
let's make sure that we're one for today
yeah
looks like
see two main site okay
so it looks like we didn't have to do it
in fact I completely forgot that by
default Google Analytics doesn't show
you the stuff from the current day so it
was actually just showing me from like
the last week or so I forget what the
range was so when I set it to show
today's stuff it actually did work from
localist so that part worked so since
we've kind of gotten into this big mess
now anyway with the servers I am going
to fix that quickly but basically this
works so let's go back and let's add
this
I'm not going to update the other server
just yet which is going to it shouldn't
cause a problem for the two minutes that
it's going to take to fix this so let's
go over let's go over here back to our
page and we need to do two things one on
events we need to not prefetch let's see
photos up here someone let me it's dumb
yeah it's down here okay so and
eventually all this stuff will be out of
our code anyway and it will be pulled in
through the WordPress API but for now
for now let's get rid of this this
prefetch
and I'm wondering now should I get rid
of whatever I should get rid of all of
it let's just let's see I'm going to say
that hopefully that'll fix the issue now
you know it might not because we're
still getting the 404 so
let me bring it back that error here so
the error is trying to go to saying this
doesn't exist let's see if we'll get the
same error see if we can go on our our
test version of this which I'll pull it
over so the test version let's inspect
this okay so I'm not getting that error
and our test version but I'm still I'm
getting the 404 but then it then it
works okay so now I am getting that
error see I'm getting this error here so
here's what we're going to do let's go
that's that's really odd
it's an odd air so basically I'm just
going to remove this link and I'm not
going to use the link I'm just going to
use a regular a tag and we'll try that
out and see if that works so
see
- oh right
all right let me check we're getting to
the end I'm going to have to finish up
soon for my three o'clock meeting so I'm
going to check the live chat quickly
just see if there's any questions you
all have let's see all Patrick mentioned
you could put that in a bastion alias oh
that long string of commands that I
copied and pasted in when we were trying
to shut off the server and then update
it and restart it he says you can put
that in a bash alias and you can I do
recommend doing that I just haven't done
it yet but I do want to do that for now
and especially because it's just me
working on it for the most part it's
just easy for me to just copy it over
but it would be a better idea to to make
a batch alias for it okay
so we've taken this we've just made it a
regular a tag let's click it and see
what happens so I'm gonna see that looks
good alright that looks good only bad
thing is we're not getting our
client-side routing you see we got a
full page refresh I don't like that but
I think it's ok it's ok for now I'm not
sure if we can have the client-side
routing when we've because for this
we've used custom so we've edited our
server ojs file and we've used some
custom routing to use parameterised
routing so that's like outside the scope
of what next does so I'm thinking maybe
the next client-side routing system
can't work with that I don't know but
for now this is good this gives us what
we what we want for the most part so I'm
going to stick with that and let's go
back to alright so we had we were
working in footage is so this worked I
do want to make sure
I want to see where else we have this
goodness
I wonder it's just going to you very
much sooner
yeah I don't think we need to track all
these links like obviously to the
privacy policy and things like that we
don't need to track that so I think
we're good we're good tracking that you
said we have one in the sit in the head
I mean maybe the nav yeah oops
and there's my Google my calendar for my
meeting
oh yeah um okay so we need to track this
yeah I need to check this let me make
sure I'm a cantina okay I have ten
minutes so let's do the same thing with
this one hopefully it our class name
stuff still works as well let's pull in
this and we at nav
and
[Music]
this react actually with time today you
know I'm not going to do this right now
because two things one I want to answer
your questions and live chat also I want
to make sure I sort out this server
thing before I have my meeting so we'll
stop here because I can always basically
we've got it working so for the purpose
of you know figuring out how to do this
we've done it we've accomplished it we
just need to apply the same thing to a
few other places so that's worked what
we need to do now is push our change up
to github so the change we made to the
to the length so we got rid of the
prefetching to get rid of the
client-side routing we just used to read
your link and then that that fix the
errors we were getting
okay
shoot okay so you see the areas we're
getting where we define some things and
never used it basically we added this
and nav and we're not going to use it
yet so we'll just add that back in at
some point and then in footer not footer
events we added in the link but then now
we're not going to use that anymore so
very useful to to check this stuff out
beforehand and
[Music]
whoa okay I just saw this in the lab
chat so Sebastian says check issue
number 71 for react GA it says browsers
block react GA length hmm
that might be an issue I'm still going
to push this change to fix the other
thing but I'm going to come back to that
after my meeting though and check out
that issue because that could definitely
a problem all right okay so if you're
not familiar with github
we've just committed our changes and
then we're pushing them up to github on
the master branch now I can go in here
to our server and let me run our our set
of commands that we've been copying so
actually go back out the commands assume
that I'm not already in the directory
for the project
so hopefully this all works now we don't
get any errors we can test it quickly
and hopefully it works all right let me
go through world boss asks you have a
bachelors yes I do have a bachelor's
degree I have a bachelor's degree in
business
sharmi says usually master's degree for
people who love to do research or an
academics or the company requires that
for our position yeah you're right a lot
of times higher degrees are for research
stuff I know at least the United States
a lot of people get master's degrees in
business and then they can get higher up
in their organization even though they
don't do any research that's so that's
you know the only other reason that I've
seen for them else like if you want to
teach like normally they don't let you
teach anything at a university unless
you add the very least have a master's
degree prefer a doctorate so that's
another reason why some people get them
all right so let's check it out
and what do we have it maybe I pulled it
over to a different place I think this
was the one where we actually went see
that pulled us over to the other server
let me try to let me great try to grab
the IP address again see if we can get
straight there
so see without with our load balancers
right now is taking us to the older
version of the site that's on our other
server let's see hmm still taking us CEO
sir
mmm
all right well let's
let's see shoot I run this again okay
okay so now we should be good to run run
these commands okay all right back to
the latch at get in this I have two
minutes so sorry if I can't get to all
your questions
[Music]
okay so it looks like looks like I'm
going to I am going to need to check out
the issue where with blouse browsers
blocking blocking the links from react
GA so um Patrick says it might be a
target --blank issue so I'm going to
test that out after my meeting sorry
didn't really have a Q&A this time get
to it definitely next time hopefully I
won't have another meeting tomorrow but
anyway thank you all for for watching
thanks for your help my meetings in one
minute so I have to go but I should be
back should be back tomorrow and if
anybody has any helpful links I know you
guys were talking about some issues and
stuff please post it in the live chat or
message me on Twitter or something
because I do want to figure out this
problem as soon as my meeting is over
all right but anyway I'll see you
tomorrow have a great day